Ella es la enfermera siduan una de las
afectadas por la alta inflación ha
tenido que acudir a este banco de
alimentos
creo que la razón por la que he venido a
un banco de alimentos es porque la vida
ahora es bastante difícil tengo un
crédito universal que no es suficiente
para vivir porque la inflación está
subiendo muy rápidamente todos sube
bueno Dice que no puede comprar lo que
solía y que le es muy difícil llegar a
fin de mes con lo que gana la primera
vez que acudía este banco fue para decir
Necesito ayuda necesito ayuda necesito
alimentar a mis hijos necesito
alimentarme a mí misma porque estaba
pasando por un momento difícil sin tener
ni siquiera tres comidas al día quizás
una o dos comidas al día lo que no es
suficiente para el supervisor del banco
de alimentos la situación no se
vislumbra fácil
estoy muy preocupado por este invierno
creo que va a ser un espectáculo de
error todavía hace calor Así que puede
que la gente aún no haya encendido la
electricidad los calentadores y demás y
cuando tengan que hacerlo les será aún
más difícil
Y es que los precios de la energía van
en aumento en toda Europa y con la
llegada del Invierno los hogares podrían
verse abocados a decidir entre comprar
comida o pagar las facturas de la
electricidad Los Altos cobros han
incidido en gran medida en el índice de
precios al consumo en septiembre llegó
hasta el 10,1% anual frente al 9,9 de
agosto el nivel más alto de los últimos
40 años